Іра, покажеш сир.
Та зачекай! Хай заглянуть в бочку.
Чи на неї не можна дивитись?
А, можна! Непоганий вийшов! Тільки горить.
Горить. Зараз. Треба...
Палиці немає.
Це наш місцевий вид сиру,
який ми винайшли, скажімо так.
Свобода — це таке відносне поняття.
Ми від чогось звільняємось,
а від чогось стаємо залежними.
То ми залежали від таких факторів як...
соціальні, політичні...
А тепер більше нас хвилює
погода, сонце, активність...
[сміється]
Дощ: є він чи немає.
Чи плодючі у нас ґрунти чи ні.
Ну, так нам цікавіше.
Це більше схоже на те, що нам потрібно.
Ходили на роботу так, як більшість людей.
Платили за газ, за електроенергію,
слідкували за тарифами,
за подіями, які розвертаються.
Думали, що це правда все.
[сміється]
А тепер у нас інша правда трошки... своя.
Ми створили невеличку таку свою систему
і граємося з нею, як хочемо.
В своє задоволення.
Я в свій час мріяла про таке місце.
Про таке життя. Про таку свободу.
А Діма, мабуть, теж.
Хотілось йому творчості.
Як це було? Власне кажучи, таким...
Це, мабуть, було десь взимку.
Було прийнято рішення.
Ми вирішили купити велосипеди і...
разом кататись, дивитись,
шукати підходяще місце.
І почали кружляти навколо того міста,
там в мережі ми жили, по радіусам, які збільшувались.
І от зараз ми на радіусі 25 кілометрів.
[сміється]
Те, що до того ми бачили, нам не подобалось.
А він приїхав і сказав: «Я знайшов».
І потім ми потрапили сюди аж через місяць.
І потрапили на те місце,
де зараз будинок.
І таке відчуття, я вам не можу передати,
коли от ми сиділи там на тому белебні, це ж все був схил.
І сидиш, а воно...
Це жовтень був же, так?
Жовтень, початок жовтня.
І сидиш, сонце в чоло, і так...
Ну, так добре, приємно. Я кажу:
«Тут так класно! Я хочу тут жити!»
Бабине літо.
Так, кіз не видно, ну,
власне кажучи, вони тут живуть.
Кіз треба пасти, треба доїти,
але вони практично дають продукцію цілий рік.
Тому ми зайняті, і ми при ділі,
і якийсь у нас є заробіток.
Це село. Взагалі-то це село.
Щоб ви не думали, що ви потрапили
в бур'яни якісь. Це центр села.
Он трансформатор є.
Вулиця Лугова. Вулиця Центральна.
Оце центр нашого села Гришківка,
якому 360 з гаком років.
А скіфські могили датовані ще
пів тисячі років до нашої ери.
Тобто люди тут живуть постійно.
Ну от тепер наша черга прийшла.
Ми зробили заявку на захід,
який проводили екобудівельники.
Презентували свій проєкт і сказали:
«Ми ось будуємо там і там, хто хоче, може приїздить».
Перший доброволець, який приїхав, сказав:
«Якось я прокинувся вранці, відчуваю таку потребу
у всьому організмі комусь допомогти збудувати будинок.
Відкриваю Інтернет,
знаходжу ваше оголошення і телефоную».
Отак вони й знаходились.
Тепле місце, це просто яма така,
накрита прозорим покриттям.
Називається «валіпіні».
Ну, в Інтернеті можна такий знайти термін.
Заглиблена теплиця.
Водопостачання у нас вирішується на місці.
Ось, скажімо, скважина п'ятнадцятиметрова.
Отаким чином здобувається вода,
щоб напоїти діжаки, які тут стоять
або полити рослини.
Качнув літр води, викачав.
У нас таке природнє помешкання.
Це три з половиною тисячі мішків з землею.
Ось у вас є земля, її складаєте в мішки,
з мішків складаєте в якусь купу.
Помазали і з середини накрили,
щоб не текло, і живете.
Це наш будинок приблизно такий.
Будинок трошки завеликий,
як за моїми сьогоднішніми мірками,
але в ньому живе постійно 5 чоловік,
тобто двоє синів, дочка і нас двоє.
Ну, 56 квадратних метрів —
це, в принципі, на 5 чоловік нормально.
Круглий він тому, що ця технологія
передбачає будівництво округлих стін.
Мішки лежать, не зв'язані нічим, власне кажучи,
як, наприклад, цегла цементним розчином.
Їх можна розібрати і зібрати.
А круг більш міцний, ніж квадрат в 17 разів.
В будинку є вода, водозабезпечення.
Там ручний насос.
Гаряча вода, коли топиться піч,
каналізація,
ну, власне кажучи, всі необхідні умови.
Стіни у нас земляні, підлога земляна,
стеля земляна, ну, меблі, звісно, земляні.
Чого? Бо ми землероби.
[сміється]
Землероб повинен робити землю, повинен
робити все на землі і з землі, що хочеш, може зробити.
От вам приклад цього.
Ми селяни.
Живемо в своє задоволення, живемо так, як хочемо.
І залежно від того, які надлишки у нас з'являються,
ми пропонуємо їх тим людям,
які симпатизують нам і які хочуть цього.
Доставку робимо по Харкову.
Тут у нас повна відповідальність за наше життя.
Ми не ходимо на роботу, ми створюємо її.
І тому, хто,
ну, може, хоче приїхати в село і
знайти там роботу, це тупіковий шлях.
Тут ти приїжджаєш і ти створюєш собі роботу сам.
Займаєшся нею і, власне кажучи,
тут місце для того, щоб бути самим собою.
Якщо це не твоє,
то краще в іншому десь місці знайти своє щастя.
В полі вирощуємо корми, там,
як я вам сказав, вище, спекотніше.
Що росте?
Ну, росте, загалом, все, що нам необхідно.
Тут у нас нижче городи, там поле.
Таким от чином у нас харчовий
ланцюг вибудовується.
Спочатку мені нагадувало про те,
що колись ми там виростили помідори.
«О, свої помідори!». Потім там виростили картоплю.
Там помідори і картопля.
Ви отримуєте результати своєї праці
і це додає вам сили і бажання далі працювати.
А ще коли це приносить користь
ще й іншим людям, ті ж харчі, які я їм...
Я їм сама, і родина їсть,
і годуємо інших.
І це корисно.
Це дуже велике таке задоволення.
Козли — це дороговартісне задоволення.
В якому розумінні: вони, власне,
потрібні тільки на момент весілля з козами.
Це там кілька секунд,
може, хвилина роботи в рік,
але вони самі по собі коштують грошей,
і їх треба утримувати, годувати цілий рік.
Красунчик росте на зміну Сепові,
а Сеп змінює Кіная.
[сміється]
Кінай — козел чистопородний,
а це білий німецький.
Ось він, хлопець!
Такий...
з гумором.
Чим цей козел цікавий, він дає молоко.
З козла можна отримати молока,
тільки дуже мало, тобто «як з козла молока».
Там, «з тебе користі, як з козла молока» —
це означає, користь все-таки є якась,
але дуже мало і не з усякого козла.
Ну, було багато складних моментів,
особливо на початку,
коли природа тебе виштовхує,
а тобі все одно хочеться, і потім вона тебе приймає.
Ну оці переломні моменти,
коли все ж таки думалось,
що може, не зможу, да?
А потім, коли воно все розбиралося,
все ж таки, по кінцівці, ні!
Все ж таки хочеться бути тут.